je vais traverser l'océan pacifique
parcourir 5000 milles nautiques et
prouver que les péruviens ont été les
premiers à peupler la polynésie
la distance c'est plus grande contre
chicago et moscou
regardez autour de vous dans chacun de
ses livres scientifiques développe une
théorie monsieur et jordaan le récit
d'une poignée de norvégiens qui se noie
dans le pacifique sera très vendeur pour
de nombreux magazines mais pas pour
celui ci vous voulez qu'on croit votre
théorie alors allez-y
laissez-vous dérivés depuis le pérou
jusqu'en polynésie sur un radeau en bois
de balsa il n'y aura rien ni personne
pour sauver c'était votre théorie on
aura fini d'en baver lire tout ce que
j'espère c'est que dans trois mois des
enfants auront encore un père
il n'y a pas d'autres routes que le
courant est coté riels su quand on ne
peut pas manoeuvrer
pas la peine d'espérer changer de cap
il faut y croire et à personne sur ce
radeau qui partage ta foi otegi quelque
chose qui nous dépasse
je ne sais pas